all right
i wanna i wanna talk about something
very serious oh yeah i am deeply
offended and i'm gonna start this
segment by saying one thing
i could be watching a movie
right and it's an action movie maybe a
james bond film and you know the the
action hero pulls out his gun and just
shoots a bunch of dudes
and they die
i feel nothing
but that scene when the dog gets it by a
car
then i'm like
john wick
exactly yeah oh like john wick just went
around slaughtering people and you're
just like yeah you get him why because
they killed his dog
from the independent
bidens have given away dog major to
family friends after biting incidents
first family of the united states is
re-homing their dog citing that it would
be safest for major
yo that's some dark stuff like i get it
sometimes people have to do stuff like
this but the reality is they use the dog
as a prop joe biden's got a strong dog
then the dog bites people and like get
rid of them quick yeah i tweeted about
this like if you don't have time to
raise a dog profit really you shouldn't
be getting more dogs and to give one
away i mean that probably breaks the
heart of the dog that that totally is
just disrespectful nasty irresponsible
behavior and and you know if you have a
dog that's trouble you have to train
them again i'm a dog owner i also have
german shepherds german shepherds are
the second leading uh breed of dog that
uh are related to attacks you know when
you have a dog like that it's like
having a gun when you have a gun you
need to be responsible for it you need
to learn how to use it you need to make
sure that you're not going to hurt
anyone else with that i took you know my
you know
my dog parenting very seriously i train
my dog i run my dog almost every single
day
you have to because they're they're
creatures that deserve all of your time
and if you're a bureaucrat that clearly
one is not right up there not all there
health-wise you think you're going to
have another dog that you're responsible
for of course that other dog's going to
be biting more people but they got
another dog that's crazy they just
replaced it for a new dog named for a
new puppy yeah i don't believe for a
minute that this dog was re-homed i
think this is pure propaganda i have no
facts to back this claim up but what i
think is that that dog took one look at
uh you know 90 year old joe biden
chasing him out of the shower and he ran
and never came back
i think remember that story right i
remember yeah he slipped in the shower
or whatever the dog yeah that dog was
out of there he was just like i don't
need this i don't need this like no they
said 20 years ahead of me you know dogs
can smell uh seizures before they happen
yeah
so that's crazy dogs can smell cancer
what if dogs can smell evil they can't
mm-hmm and like joe biden is in like you
know the conservatory or whatever they
have in the white house and like the
dogs in the in the corner like
snarling and joe budden's like stop
snarling we have to do a photo shoot and
the dog's like
and then they're like get rid of him
and so they bring in this puppy and the
puppies too too confused and doofy to
yeah you know understand that he's the
the the odor coming off him is evil
pure evil
quite possible i can see that that makes
sense to me yeah that checks out yep i
heard that i heard that dogs can smell
if you've eaten dog
i believe that yeah i had heard that i
have rumors about that i haven't heard
if that's true but they're extremely
intuitive they're extremely smart
especially german shepherds they know
what's going on um and and if you don't
raise them right they could be some of
the worst dogs that you could ever have
and they are
they have a tendency to to lash out and
be angry especially when you don't pay
attention to them especially if you
don't give them a lot of time
and to see these kind of dogs use this
used as props and to just be thrown away
it's it's sick and disgusting
irresponsible behavior and i wouldn't
expect anything else from the federal
government they get a fake dog so they
can be like look we got a dog look how
cute now they got it they got a new dog
named commander or whatever which is
another german shepherd right yeah
yeah the same uh same kind of yo german
shepherds need training yep a lot of
training and a lot of exercise i have a
german shepherd i love my german
chocolate aren't they like the closest
breed to wolves or something yes i was
reading about this so for joe biden to
be like we want a prop dog and they
probably had a consultant come in and be
like now german shepherds you know they
they they test very very well in our
pulse so you can either go with a husky
or a german shepherd
don't do the labradoodle and they're
like we'll go with the german shepherd
he's like well now german shepherds
require a lot of training and joe
biden's like
yeah you want to look tough that's what
you want to have in shefford and
you know it's great marketing but but
again a huge responsibility and there's
so much training to go into trump should
get a labradoodle yeah
pug i think
pugs also great dogs what if trump just
had like two massive pit bulls with them
all the time like just super huge and
they walked to his left and his right
and they're just like
that'd be pretty awesome
the babylon bee had a great headline
saying the bidens are going to name
their dog carl barks which is it's right
on the money
um
but disappointed to see so many dogs
just kind of thrown away and and it's
bad for especially german shepherds
german shepherds are dogs that need a an
alpha need a primary owner and if they
don't and if they keep getting kind of
thrown around between different owners
and they don't kind of have uh their one
owner
they get lost and confused and they're
not happy dogs when they don't have that
one person in their life that they have
to serve look at this story is kind of
sickening to me
npr the bidens say hello to new puppy
commander and major is off to a new home
horrible and then they have this tweet
meet the newest biden welcome home
commander it's just like they threw out
one dog and bought another one of the
same breed
yeah it's just exactly what happened
well that's uh that's how joe biden will
treat you
as an american that's right no no wait
people are asking that my dog bite
michael mouse no that wasn't my dog
i trained my dog yeah and
yeah yeah when we were doing the uh the
crazy show michael had the thing on his
face yeah because nick's dog bit his
face yeah yeah i didn't know what it was
and then
bit my dog that's right and right this
ripped her face too yeah and oh my god
but that's um what what is that is that
a husky
um i think it's a shepherd mix of some
sort but no you got to train your dogs
man absolutely people think this is a
joke and you can get a puppy and uh and
joe biden's doing it again how much you
want to bet commander goes off and bites
somebody in what six months i am i'm
gonna place money on that and i think
part of the reason that um major wasn't
happy with joe biden was because he's a
terrible leader and it turns out that he
actually is for the rest of the country
as well but he probably didn't respect
him as like yeah
well germans you with german shepherds
you need an alpha you need someone who's
confident because if the german shepherd
sees that you're not confident
they're gonna try to walk all over you
like atlas challenges me my dog
challenges me all the time i'm like no
no you're not gonna get away with this
it's not gonna work here uh but but if i
kind of let loose and don't train her
and and and you know don't do the proper
work with her she's not going to
obviously be a good dog and she's going
to be disrespectful and and obviously
biden doesn't have time to raise a dog
right now so there's no way that german
shepherd is going to be raised properly
um and and then as you mentioned tim
germany shepherds are very much like uh
wolves and i had a dog trainer say if
you want to understand german shepherds
just watch documentaries about wolves um
and i did and there's a huge learning
curve fascinating animals but again it's
just like anything they also have a
potential to be very dangerous
you need to be responsible for it people
are going to get hurt dogs are going to
get hurt it's it's not being a jerk it's
not just that it's take responsibility
for for the animals you have you know
what i mean like if you get a dog that's
your problem you got to figure it out
but joe biden clearly got the dog as a
prop that's the thing
well you mentioned that maybe like how
he treated the former biden dog is how
he's going to treat us what if it's not
maybe we're looking at this sideways
here what if it he's actually worried
it's not about controlling where the dog
is it's about the dog's safety that's
why he re-homed it
sure sure that's what i was saying for
sure yeah maybe maybe not control we do
need to be secure yeah maybe he could
get some pugs and teach them how to do
the the black power paw oh it'd be great
well it was a little bit more severe
than the black power part no he did a
second iteration
and he and and that video was was way
funnier than the first one oh okay
so i haven't watched it yet but i need
to watch that you haven't seen it dude
it's actually i saw that i've seen the
first one yeah i got him in trouble yeah
so the second one he did is like
he's he's you know he's got the teaching
the dog or whatever what else needs to
knock on the door and he's like he's
like oh crap it's the labor party and
then he like has to hide a bunch of
books books one of the book he has to
hide is the torah yeah
oh my gosh because you know
you know because they're anti-semites
yeah man that's funny i i think this is
an example of um
it's a combination of callousness
irresponsibility
and um
i think it exemplifies a lot about what
uh like the administration has been in
terms of their like
what's the right word i'm trying to
think of just like their capacity you
know what i mean like biden i don't
think if he was running against anybody
else would ever win right but because
there were so many people who didn't
like trump people were like i'll take
whatever i can get the corporeal form
they called it right well what do you
get with that you get weak leadership
you get callousness you get lazy
uh behavior and you can get joe biden uh
half measures
and you're gonna get a whole bunch of
people bit and hurt that's right and
a whole bunch of you know dogs that
don't have a true you know owner and uh
have a horrible life should we get like
should we get like one of those pools
where you like put dates and then we
figure out like how long it's gonna last
and everyone can buy a square and
we'll be like this is gonna last three
months this dog's gonna become you know
at six months and they're going to be
like oh look you know joe biden what was
the story about him in the bathtub the
shower or whatever he slipped well i
mean who oh he broke his foot or
something right yeah he liked
the story was so bizarre like i can't
remember all the details but basically
they said that he was trying to pet the
dog after a shower and he fell down and
he hurt himself and none of it added up
and it all created really horrifying
imagery that i won't forget yeah some
people said it was a cover-up for a
bigger medical procedure dealing with
his brain and aneurysms and that's why
he had this cover story that was so
elaborative that didn't make any sense
at all yeah but what's the evidence for
that
a lot of speculation and theories and
the fact that he also has very serious
injuries still within his head uh i
believe it's what corrected me from
wrong metal stints two metal stints in
his head yeah he had two what do you
have aneurysms or something yeah it is
yeah but this was like decades and
decades ago so yeah but there could be
some yeah there it's it needs to be
checked up on there needs to be some
very serious procedures that people need
to take that's associated with that and
do you think joe biden gets blood
infusions from children probably yeah
that's the basic stuff it's probably
even bigger than that well so i mean i
mean i bring that up because i know
it'll be very triggering to a lot of
people on the left they're going to be
like oh don't say that that's conspiracy
but we know a lot of rich people and
powerful individuals they get they get
blood transfusions from young people and
so like a lot of these billionaires
actually hire bodybuilders to like just
go to the gym and be a gym rat eat
healthy and then once every two weeks
they get a blood infusion from their not
just whatever blood but also fecal
matter there's also
people there's a south park episode
about that exactly
and there is science behind that that
blood uh kind of therapy that is
implemented in some parts of mexico
already and there are a lot of
billionaires financing more scientific
discoveries and studies into that and it
wouldn't surprise me we don't have any
kind of evidence it's kind of
circumstantial to kind of allude that
this could be happening but uh you know
there's some probability that yes that's
that's probably what's going on there's
probably what's going on with henry
kissinger and a whole bunch of other
stuff that they're getting that gives
them life extension technology and
allows them to live all the way up until
the 80s and 90s that's uh i mean david
rockefeller was 101. thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time
you